[Music]
hello youtube chess lovers and my
friends this is gunjan here
welcome to my 66 episode of dirty chess
tricks
well many people knows that three nights
is one of my favorite opening weapon and
in fact
i have created a video on that in my
dirty chest tricks 43 episode
however in the recent time i have faced
a amazing trap line against it
and today i am going to share some of
the secrets
and high profile tricks exist
in that line
my games start with the pattern of
defense so we have the following
opening model e4 e5
knight to f3 and now rather than
defending the e5 pawn by playing
knight to c6 black choose the move
knight to f6 counter-attacking the white
pawn
the good thing about this line is it
doesn't matter
whether white continue with knight
captures e5 main line
or the move which i choose in the game
knight to c3
so now i defend the pawn and all set to
capture on e5
and that's why the main line continue
with
knight to c6 however
my opponent come up with this very rare
but very tricky move bishop to c5
and you can already see what is already
in the dilemma
because if he doesn't take the pawn and
continue with
bishop to e2r bishop to c4 then black
can continue with
knight to c6 which is converting
into the very good version of the
italian game
so more or less if white wants to get
any advantage
then he has to take the spawn which in
fact
i did in the game
so as the e pawn is firmly protected
white is not much bother about queen to
e7 nuisance
however my opponent continue here with
his tricky style
starting with knight to c6
offering the advanced staffer gambit
structure
now here if white doesn't take this
knight and goes back
then black can respawn with d5
and with the leading development with
most likely opposite side castle
scenario
black has an ample compensation for the
loss of
pawn so once again in order to keep the
advantage
white has to take this knot and after a
black recapture with the d-pawn
we have reached the critical tricky
platform
of this line
now before we look further the important
point i like to highlight here that
we can reach to this position via
different move order
so for example instead of playing the
moon knight to c3 here
if white continue with knight captures
e5
then we can respond with knight to c6
staffer gambit territory and after
knight capture c6
and pawn capture c6
only difference here is you need to
prepare the line
against the move e5 or d3 by white
but knight to c3 is also one of the main
response
and after this we directly transpose
into our tricky platform with the move
bishop to c5
well any white player naturally continue
with
either the move bishop to c4 or bishop
to e2
planning to castle quickly but in fact
this is where our tricks straight away
comes into the picture
first let me show you what happens after
bishop to c4
which is in fact i played in my game
but to my surprise after my opponent's
next reply
more or less white has lost the plot
so before i move on guys i want you to
find a sequence
where black is completely winning
from this position
are you ready let's start the first move
is
very obvious knight to g4 attacking on
f2
and in fact there is no good way to
defend on f2
except to castle on the king's side
and white will be indeed happy if he can
play the mood d4
in the next turn but nope
that is not going to happen as after
black's next
amazing reply yup
you guessed it queen to h4
and suddenly not only there is a mate on
horizon
with queen captures s2 but there are
three attackers on f2
which cannot be defended
here the fourth supply is h3
but sadly after knight captures f2
hit his earlier device to even continue
the game
why what's so special about this move
well the first thing is first this black
knight
is attacking the queen and if white
try to save the queen let's say queen to
e1
then we have this force mating pattern
let's see if you can find it i am
showing you right now
knight captures h3 double discover check
doesn't matter wherever the king goes
king to h1
once again we are going to deliver this
double check
with knight to f2 and after king to g1
and the move queen to h1 you really want
to invite your friend
and show them this wonderful chat mate
so that means here white has to take
this knight
with rook captures f2 but even after
this
he is not out of the wood as bishop
captures f2
and the only move to keep white in the
game is king to f1
because the natural move king to h1
leads to another big disaster
yup bishop captures h3 and the game is
finished
right there
well you might think hang on there is no
need for bishop to c4
as i can play the move bishop to e2
stopping any nuisance of knight to g4
and isn't white is a clear pawn up
in the scenario
of course not as black attack continued
with
queen to d4 attacking one f2 and after
castle
the star move h5 and believe it or not
this position is more venomous than you
think
in fact some good players has reached to
this position
and the most frequent choice by the way
here is either to play
h3 or d3 which i'm afraid
not enough to save the game
let's see each by turn and find out why
this position is such
dangerous for the white camp
in the first game white player in excess
of 2300 rated
continue with h3 trying to stop the
night intrusion
but guess what black says nob sweetie
i am going to come anyways
well more or less white has to take this
knight
otherwise f2 pawn drops
with a huge consequences so in the game
white rightly remove this dangerous
knight
but the net result is after h captures
g4
the etch file open up with the rook
and black has a deadly threat
let's continue with a random move from
white let's say white is not
aware of it and continue with d3
liberating his last piece but
unfortunately for him
after queen to e5 the game is finished
right there do you think about g3
congratulations because after queen
captures g3
white indeed get checkmated
so that's the big time threat here guys
and
rightly so white sensing the danger
and continue with g3 at this point
okay black move is very obvious queen to
e5
threatening queen captures g3 checkmate
so white stop it with the move king to
g2
and i'm sure at this point white is more
than happy as
he can meet the threat of queen to h5
with fluke to h1
and currently he has neutralized all the
threat
but just one big blow and white all
imagination evaporated did you see it
you are a genius if you find bishop
captures after
bam what a move
obviously if king takes then rook to h2
is a very strong reply
so in the game white choose the obvious
practical response
rook captures f2 but after
queen to h5 believe it or not
even though white is two piece up in
this position
he just resigned the game as
black has multiple threads which in fact
cannot be easily dealt
by the way chess engine gives black plus
for advantage
even though he is two piece down
so you can easily see s3 doesn't stop
our knight to g4 right here so in our
second game
white tried some more resilience with
d3 and after the moon knight to g4
he calmly defended with the move queen
to e1
what i like about this line is that
every move is so consistent
and if you remember the last game you
can easily see the next black reply
yup queen to e5 trying to deliver
the checkmate okay
black stop it with the move g3
and now no second invitation required
yup h4 ripping apart whole
white king side in fact
the game finished very quickly with
bishop to f4 attacking the queen
queen to h5 dorvious response
and now seeing the h-file is going to
open up
and his king will be in great danger
white played the ultimate blunder
with king to g2 and after that
black just killed the white in a star
edge captures g3 edge captures g3
queen check king to f3
and now lovely move knight captors have
to
bam well the threat is very obvious
bishop to g4 and checkmate the white
king
so white has to take this knight with
rook captures f2
but to his horror he found out that
he got this head shot with
bishop to g4 jack and white simply
resigned
as his king has no space to hide
and the obvious move king captures g4
completely fails
due to queen to h5 once again
a picturesque chat mate on the board
that's it guys i hope you enjoy and
learn this
high profile tricky line against three
nights
remember once you reach to this position
it doesn't matter
however white respond the big idea
knight to g4 is almost gives black
a winning combination just within the
opening stage
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment
and i will meet you in my next episode
very soon
bye and take care